coming up on 5 56 on your friday morning
you
yeah
you can help decide where i 11 goes
through las vegas come on along we're
centennial bowling
so we mentioned this last week when we
talked about how there's a good chance i
11 is going to head north out of town
where the 95 meets the northern 250
beltway well i hope you know that i11
comes into nevada at hoover dam
bypassing boulder city then tagging
along on what a lot of folks still call
the 95 515 up to the southern 215
beltway but how will it get from there
to the centennial bowl
in addition to the online public
information meeting that opened up on
tuesday runs until the end of next month
there are five in-person meetings
scheduled the first one's right around
the corner it's going to be at the
sahara west library tuesday august 31st
now we got the list of the dates times
locations of all the meetings in the
online version of this story but i can
tell you they're in all different parts
of the valley from right around the
centennial bowl down to henderson to
downtown las vegas as well as the south
end of the valley just go to our website
eightnewsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully put down that phone if there
is something driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eight newsnow dot com